[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELSIE KENYON: Hello, everyone.
My name is Elsie Kenyon, and
I'm excited to be here today
with my colleagues
from Two Sigma.
Now, Two Sigma is an
investment manager
which applies data
science and technology
to find value in the
world's financial markets.
So why, you may ask, are we
here today to talk about games?
Well, in Two Sigma's
17-year cultural history,
there have been many
successful internal challenges
organized around games.
You may have seen a YouTube
video of our air hockey robot
competition.
We found that these games-- and
particularly games that pair
humans with machines--
are really unique opportunities
for applying new skills
to difficult challenges.
Two years ago, Two Sigma
interns, Ben and Michael, here
today, created an entirely
new such game, Halite,
in which players build bots
that play the games for them.
The Halite Artificial
Intelligence Competition
was so successful
within Two Sigma
that we opened up the
competition globally,
open sourced the code base,
and repeated the process
the next year with
a brand new game.
This fall will launch the
Third Annual Halite Artificial
Intelligence Competition.
Now, to date, there have
been thousands of players
from over 100 countries
that have played Halite.
These player-submitted
bots have been
written in over 20
different languages
and have played
millions of games.
Now, on the one hand, a
global programming competition
has provided Two Sigma with
a new source for identifying
strong talent, but there
is another stronger promise
of Halite.
At the top of this
Halite II leaderboard,
you'll see professionals,
university students,
and even a high school
student at number four.
We've seen players of all ages
and experience levels engaged
with advanced algorithms,
AI, and machine
learning via this
immersive game on their own
and with each other.
This is Halite I.
The rules of the game
can be explained in a
paragraph, but the game
has a branching factor many
times that of the game of Go.
It's an open-ended environment
in which many strategies
can be successful.
This laboratory-like
nature is a feature
of Halite, which you'll
understand further
as Ben and Michael contextualize
Halite in the history of games
and share the principles
guiding Halite's development.
Running Halite requires
significant back end resources.
Jack will explain how Google
Cloud enabled Two Sigma
to run a global AI competition
at scale with no downtime.
We consider Halite a game
designed for this era in AI
and this era in technology,
and we hope by the end of today
that you will, too.
Now I'll hand it over
to Michael and Ben.
MICHAEL: Thank you.
BEN: Thanks, Elsie.
So-- back to one.
OK.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about the Halite games,
the predecessors, the process,
the principles, and all
of that.
We want to start
with an introduction
of the evolution
of games and how
Halite fits into that history.
And as you know, all
presentations need a cute
picture of cats to
succeed-- here is ours--
but it also has an actual
meaning for the presentation,
too.
I think we often conceptualize
of games as a uniquely
human thing, but they're not.
We see games with
animals all the time.
Here, these cubs
are play wrestling
so that when they have to
wrestle for real later in life,
they'll be ready.
We think that this leads to
an important use of games--
that really, games, under one
viewpoint, under one lens,
are about learning, that a game
is an environment with very
low risk in which you can
try new strategies and ideas,
explore, hone your skills, so
that when it actually matters,
you'll be ready.
And continuing on in that
thread, just a little bit
about some early strategy
games that stick around today,
there are earlier games
like Egyptian games of dice
that precede these games,
but the ones that have really
remained popular are these games
of strategies-- primarily Go
and chess, which originated
about 2,500 years ago,
and then chess about
1,000 years later.
And what's key about these
games is that, in their time,
they've both been considered
these tools for learning
strategy that, as a
military commander,
you'd be expected to be
good at chess in addition
to a good military commander.
There was thought that
there is some transfer
of the skill between them.
But that also, we see games
kind of come into their own
as a form of art.
I think we might have this
idea that games as art
is very modern, in that now we
have all sorts of video games
that are artistic and take
you through some story and all
that, but really,
this originates
a lot earlier with these games.
MICHAEL: All right, so the
history of games and machines
is definitely a lot shorter than
that of the history of humans
playing games.
It's about 50 years versus
many thousands of years.
But it is a dense
history, nonetheless,
and it mostly consists
of machines beating
humans at their own games.
The famous example is Deep
Blue becoming superhuman
on chess, and recently
AlphaGo beating Lee Sedol,
and soon, probably,
Dota 2 in StarCraft
will be beat by open AI
and DeepMind, respectively.
But what we're really
interested in with Halite
in building this competition
is making games that leverage
both the best parts of humans
and the best parts of machines.
We want to design
games where humans
need to think through
the strategies,
think through the rules,
think through the game logic,
and then design systems that are
executed by their bots nicely.
BEN: Yeah.
I think that there's
often a conception
of the progress of AI as sort
of antagonistic to humans,
that it's like, well, all
right, that's another thing
that machines are
better at than humans.
When's Skynet coming?
But we don't see it that way.
There's no reason that it has
to be adversarial like that.
One could easily imagine
a future in which humans
and machines coexist
on the same games
and learn from them
together in different ways,
and we're excited
by that prospect.
So, we're going to talk
first very briefly about some
of the predecessors of Halite,
get into the Halite games,
and then talk about the
principles behind them.
So, diving in, we start with
the Multi-Agent Programming
Contest, which is a
yearly competition that's
run since about 2005.
And the key contribution
that this really adds,
we think, to the table,
is the multi-agent aspect.
When you're controlling a bunch
of different agents at once,
the kind of techniques
that one has to use
are very different than those
when it's a single agent.
With a single agent, very
restricted number of actions,
it's usually pretty
easy to do pretty well
with something like Monte
Carlo or Minimax methods
and just some sort of valuation
function learned or hard-coded.
But once you explode the
state space with more agents,
the techniques that one has
to use become very different
and the multi-agent programming
contests really open that up.
MICHAEL: And
additionally, these games
are very hard for humans to
play in a vanilla fashion.
Unless they write either
heuristics to help guide them
through the game, or they
write boxes that are executors,
they are essentially unable to
evaluate who's winning the game
and decide what they should do.
BEN: Yeah.
And actually, one last point
about the multi-agent nature--
the fact that it is
hard for humans to play
is also a great motivator
on the educational aspect
of these games.
If you're trying to encourage
someone young to get really
interested in
programming, and they're
like, what's the point of
this, like, why do I care,
having them see
this kind of a game
that they can't actually
play effectively
but looks interesting and
that they might want to play
and then showing
them that there's
a path to this through computers
is a really effective teaching
tool, so that's another
thing that comes out of this.
MICHAEL: Yes.
The second predecessor to
Halite is the Arimaa Challenge,
which is the derivative of
chess that's made explicitly
hard for game-playing AI.
It's really impressive
since humans were actually
the best players of
this game up until 2015,
even though the game
is pretty simple.
The state space is pretty small.
You're only making
one move per turn.
But still, evaluating
the board is
extremely hard for computers.
And so we like to
think that we drew on
both detractibilty and also
the difficulty of Arimaa
in making Halite.
BEN: Yeah.
Probably the most direct
spiritual predecessor of Halite
is the UWaterloo and
Google AI Challenge.
This is the ants
competition, which was
the third and final year of it.
And what this did was it took
these previous multi-agent
competitions, and it just
completely opened it up
to the massive online scale.
Now we have thousands of users,
whereas normally, these older
programming contests were like,
you're on some mailing list,
they send it out, you
think it's kind of cool,
you develop it for
a month, and then
you submit to some conference,
and they ranked them
all in some side list
on something or another.
Now we can engage with
thousands of players.
And an important contribution is
also the real-time leader board
from the AI
challenge, and this is
what enables it to be
an educational tool that
extends broadly beyond just a
couple of individual academics.
So that brings us to,
finally, Vindinium,
which is the last
of our predecessors
that we'll mention.
It also ran concurrently
with Halite I,
so there's elements
of that, too.
And one of the really nice
things about Vindinium--
even though it's a single-agent
game and differs from Halite
in a bunch of ways--
there's a lot of core
infrastructural differences--
it's really nice visuals.
You see it, and
you're intrigued,
and you want to know
what's going on--
the sprites moving around--
it's very appealing.
MICHAEL: Yeah, and we like to
think that in making Halite,
we took something from
all four of these games.
From the Multi-Agent
Programming Competition,
we took the genre of
multi-agent games, from Arimaa,
we took the difficulty of the
game, from the AI Challenge,
we took the continuous
global leaderboard,
and from Vindinium we took
the visual appeal and theming.
And this leads in nicely to
our description of Halite
I and Halite II.
BEN: Yeah.
So we'll start off
with Halite I, which
ran between 2016 and 2017.
MICHAEL: It had
about 1,600 users
over the course of three months.
BEN: And we'll talk
about [INAUDIBLE],,
and I'll just get them out.
So, we're going to start
with the rules of it,
just to give a general
overview of them.
What you have here are
three different players
on this map, this 2D
grid, and each one
has the objective of
taking over the entire map.
Players are moving each
individual piece up,
down, left, or right each turn,
or telling it to remain still.
When they remain
still, the pieces grow.
You can see that as the size
of the square increasing.
And when they interact
with opponents,
they fight and shrink.
So, for starters,
you'll immediately
notice this abstract design.
It's very mathematical,
geometric in theming.
And, in fact, the only real
connection it has to any theme
whatsoever is the name Halite.
The name Halite came
from-- it sort of
looked like these
cubic crystals growing
was one of the analogies
that we thought of.
But a couple of important
aspects of this--
we have the really
simple rules and commands
that you just heard
basically all of the rules.
There's not that much of it.
You can easily explain it
in well under a paragraph.
And also the commands--
because you don't have multiple
types of units or anything,
you're just telling
your pieces where to go.
It's really easy to get started.
A side effect of this is
you have a very clean API
for programming.
You can have a Python bot
up in literally 10 lines
of Python, which is
just-- it's nice.
We also have the
discrete grid space.
This makes it very
easy for beginners
because arrays are such a
natural programming tool
to work with.
And finally, we have the
emergent behaviors of it.
But even though the
rules are simple,
there is a lot to
do in this game.
From working with the
combat optimization
to deciding when you want to
grow your pieces or move them,
or doing traffic control
of all of your pieces,
or deciding when
you want to expand
your territory versus
attack your opponents
and conquer new
territory, there's
a whole bunch of
separate problems
in this that all come from
these very simple rules,
and that's what makes this
game so unique and interesting.
MICHAEL: Yeah, and when
we're designing these games,
we like to say that we want
the players to play each other
and not to play the game.
And so when you make
the rule set simple,
when you're not just making
a bloated game with a bunch
of roadblocks, a bunch
of constructed problems
for players to get
through, you leave open
the possibility of
responding to other players
and having these nice
emergent behaviors.
And so this brings
us to Halite II.
This ran last year.
It had over 6,000 users.
And the game broadly
works like this.
You were the admiral
of a fleet of ships.
Every turn, you look
at all of your ships,
and you set the velocity
of each of them.
In addition-- and so the ships
exist within a continuous space
of movement.
In addition to moving, the
ships can do two things.
They can dock on
planets and planets
produce more ships
proportional to the number
of ships docked on the
planet, and they can also
fight other ships.
So loosely, when two ships
are within a certain radius,
they will automatically
attack each other.
And so the game
was, in many ways,
a response to
Halite I. We wanted
to try out some different
sorts of game design mechanics,
and one of these
is that it exists
within a continuous
space of movement.
And the advantage of this is
that users have more solutions
that they can try out.
Combat code and
navigation are actually
going to be more
complex because of this.
The drawback is that,
programmatically,
in terms of the API,
it's more difficult.
It's worse for beginners.
And so, because of
this, we actually
are probably reverting to
a grid in Halite III, which
will come out in the
fall, we should mention,
and you should go
sign up at halite.io.
Yes, and also combat was much
more difficult in Halite II.
In Halite I, it was very local.
It was, if you move a piece
onto another, they fight.
But in Halite II, you had
to do global optimization
to do combat properly.
Players actually
called it flocking.
It's when you have a group
of ships stay together,
and they single out
lone opponent ships.
They surround them and
they destroy the ship.
And then one pretty
obvious change
between Halite I and Halite II
is that now we have a theme.
We're actually tying
this to space wars,
and there are a couple
of advantages of that.
One, it's probably
easier for you all,
just looking at
the two games, not
knowing what they are,
to understand what's
happening in Halite
II versus what's
happening in Halite I. You
see ships, you see planets,
you see space.
And because of that,
we can actually
get away with some
more complex rules,
because when you think of
actually how physical movement
works, when you're
controlling a ship's lofty,
it's mathematically
pretty complicated.
But humans understand
how it works,
they come into it
with that intuition,
and we can get away with
a more interesting game.
And then finally, an important
thing we did with Halite II
is we took away AI
programmers, or deep
learning programmers,
only excuse
for not writing good bots.
That is, we provided them GPUs.
So on our servers, they
have basically the compute
they need to run whatever
gigantic convolutional
[INAUDIBLE] networks they
want or deep RL systems,
and we saw players use
that in very cool ways.
And, yeah, so this brings
us to a section on--
we're going to describe loosely
how we designed these games.
Go over some principles.
BEN: Yeah, so I'll start
with the principles.
So the first principle
of these games
is they have to be simple.
There's 10,000 things
to do on the internet.
Why should you do Halite?
Even if you should do Halite
and the rules were complicated,
it's really hard for us to
convince you to do Halite
if you have to spend
two hours learning
the ins and outs of some really
complicated set of rules.
So we took inspiration from the
game of Go with respect to this
that it's such an incredibly
simple set of rules
to work with, yet
it's been incredibly
challenging and interesting
for over thousands of years.
We really wanted to emulate
something like that.
Another side effect
of simplicity
is that you get a game
which is fast to compute,
which is usually--
well, it's advantageous
for a bunch of reasons.
First, we are running
tens of millions
of games on our server.
Fast compute lowers our
cost, which is nice.
It also makes it easier
for bot developers.
When they're testing locally
and working on their bot,
if they can run 100 games really
quickly between their own bots,
it makes it much easier
for them to iterate,
and we get better, more
interesting submissions
by the end of the competition.
A second principle is that these
games need to be very visual.
We like these bright colors
on darkish backgrounds
that pop out.
You have the movement
that catches your eye
and draws you in.
And this, again, connects
back to both the aspect
of how are we going to draw
you in, but also, how are we
going to make you stay?
When people are
developing their bots,
they're usually watching
hundreds of games
over the course of
it, maybe thousands,
as they're developing, seeing
other people's strategies
and so on.
And if it's not fun
to watch, you're
not going to want
to participate.
Last, it also helps with
the educational aspect.
It makes it much--
especially younger students
seem to care a lot more
about this aspect,
that it's much more
helpful in drawing them in.
The game needs to be
difficult to solve.
It should be evident that
tic-tac-toe would not
make a great AI competition
game because it wouldn't
last very long until
someone figured out
the dominant strategy.
And in this way, the
games that we work with
need to not just be
difficult to solve,
but they also need to be
beyond impossible to solve
so there's always a lot of room
at the top for someone to do.
You don't want a sort
of asymptotic behavior
of you getting really close
to optimal strategies.
One of the ways that we
achieve this, in part at least,
is by having an action space
which is just enormous.
The number of distinct move sets
for a standard Halite position
in Halite I was on the
order of 10 to the 1,000th.
Compare that with 300 for Go.
Not 10 to the 300,
just 300, right?
There's a lot--
Monte Carlo is just
intractable when you have
this sheer number of moves.
And the final, most amorphous--
I love this animation.
The final, most amorphous
element of the game
is that it needs to
be multidimensional.
There needs to be a
lot of different things
to do in the game so that
even if, as a developer,
you decide, OK,
I've done all that
I can do with, say, the combat
optimization element at the--
I don't know what to do next.
If that's all there
is to the game,
you'll get frustrated
and probably stop.
But we want you to say, oh,
but I have the next thing
for planet selection.
That's the next thing I need
to work on, or ship navigation,
or who knows what.
But as long as there's at
least five or six things
to work with, it makes it more
interesting at the upper level.
Then you've got differentiation
between the top players.
So some bots are good at
different kinds of things.
And also makes it
better for even
the new developer, that
there's just something for them
to always do.
So how do we design these games?
Well, the first thing
that we want to focus on
is the fact that it's
really largely iterative.
We don't know how to make these
games right the first time.
Most games will satisfy one
or two of our requirements,
but very few of them, three
or four, and almost no games
satisfy everything that we want.
What you see on the
left is the oldest image
I have from my laptop
of Halite I development,
and then on the right, the
actual finished Halite I game.
And what I hope you see are both
the similarities between them--
the grid like space and the
sort of blobish expansion with
spaces between--
but also the differences.
The size of the map
is very different.
The rules internally, which
you can't see, are different.
And there's two or
three separate games
that get us from the one
on the left to the right.
MICHAEL: Yeah.
The next thing we really try to
take to heart in cutting down
these games once we've
decided on a base set of rules
is we try, to the
best of our ability,
to reduce the number of
unit types and constants
in the game.
So when you, just
by definition, have
a lot of unit types in your
game, the length of your rules
is going to be huge.
Players are going to
have to memorize a tech
tree or the abilities of the
soldier class versus the worker
class, et cetera,
and that's fine.
That appeals to a
certain demographic.
But, for example, MIT Battle
Code has, for a decade plus,
released games that take
advantage of this unit
type classing to much success.
And their demographic
really loves it.
They enjoy scouring
through long page specs,
trying to find that one
hole in the balancing
so that they can write
the dominant strategy.
But that's just not what we're
trying to do with Halite.
We want Halite to be broadly
applicable to all programmers
on the internet.
We want them to be able
to write a bot after two
minutes of looking at our API
and looking at our game rules.
And so we really
try and reduce that.
BEN: This also, I think,
ties into the theme
of having players play
against each other
rather than against the game.
We feel that when it's about
reading through the spec
and trying to just
understand what the game is
and how to best use the flaws
for balancing of the game,
then we really feel
like you're much more
so playing against
the game than you
are against the other players.
The games are much
more interesting
when you're looking at
how players interact
with each other, which
we'll see a little bit later
in our game theory section.
The game is really just
a medium for players
to actually interact and
learn from each other.
Right?
MICHAEL: Yeah.
BEN: That brings us to the
point of emergent behaviors.
This really is just a natural
thing that comes from the fact
that we require the games to
be simple, difficult to solve,
and multi-dimensional.
So difficult to solve and
multi-dimensional basically
means that you have to have lots
of distinct, complex behaviors
that come out of it, but
yet, because it's simple,
we can't write lots
of complex rules.
So the only solution to this
is that we have simple rules,
and from those simple rules
emerge these complex behaviors.
What we have here,
what you're seeing
is Conway's Game of Life,
a certain starting state.
For those who don't know,
Conway's Game of Life
is a cellular automata,
which basically
means that the
state of each cell
depends only on the
state of its neighbors.
And the rules can be described
in like three bullet points.
It's incredibly simple.
But from these
simple rules come all
these complicated behaviors,
that you have-- on the left,
you see what are called
Glider Guns which
are producing this
infinite stream of gliders.
And then this whole
contraption is something
called a Breeder, which
produces an infinite stream
of these Glider Guns.
People have even constructed
entire Turing Machines
in Conway's Game of Life,
which shows you just the level
complexity associated with it.
So we were really
inspired by that.
We wanted to replicate that
kind of emergence with Halite I.
But there's a second
side of this coin, which
is that when the behaviors
that you're trying to design
are emergent, by definition,
you can't understand them
just by breaking it down
to the constituent pieces.
So as far as we know,
the only solution to this
is play testing.
We make games, and we see
what are the kinds of things
that we expect to
be effective are,
the things that shouldn't be
aren't, and make that all work.
If anyone knows a better
way of doing this,
please come see me
after the talk finishes.
I would love to know.
So that will take us, finally,
to targeted statistics.
This is, I think, just
more of a subpoint of this.
Often with these games,
when we're trying--
we have most of the
game figured out.
We want to just tune
certain parameters of it,
make it as interesting
as possible.
We'll sometimes also
collect statistics
that can be used to better
understand the game.
So what you're
seeing right here,
we've co-opted from
the field of economics
the Gini coefficient, which
is a statistical measure
of inequality.
We've applied it to
Halite maps to try
to figure out how production
on Halite maps is distributed.
This allows us to produce this
distribution that basically
shows us that most
maps have roughly
this level of distribution
of production through them,
but that there's also
this kind of variance.
To us, this is a good
kind of distribution,
because it shows
that, for a beginner,
you can mostly ignore the
outside of that distribution.
You can say most games I'm
going to be playing roughly
work with this kind of
math, this rough level
of distribution.
But that also, on
the outside, there's
lots of different
variety of maps
that happen less
frequently, and that
makes for some really
interesting games
every once and a while.
So that allows us to help
verify that the games that we're
making really are interesting.
MICHAEL: Yeah.
So now we're going to--
BEN: Click.
MICHAEL: Two clickers.
So now we're going to
talk in broad categories
about the solutions, the
interesting solutions
that our contestants made
for Halite I and Halite II.
I think this is a good point
to mention that, Ben and I,
we think that AI encompasses
a lot more than deep learning.
There are a lot more
interesting techniques
such as heuristic-based
models and using game theory
to solve the sorts of
problems that deep learning is
trying to solve.
BEN: Right.
And for the record,
we love deep learning.
There's a lot of
amazing research
that's come out recently in it.
We just think--
tool in the toolbox.
A lot of our users are very
inexperienced at programming.
The vast majority of them
have under three years
of experience.
So we have to make
sure that we support
all sorts of different
users, not just those that
are interested in deep learn.
MICHAEL: Yeah.
And so the most prevalent
category of solutions
to Halite I and Halite II is
just simply the heuristic bot.
And all that a
heuristic bot is is it's
just hand-coded logic,
hand-coded strategies
for playing the games of
Halite I and Halite II.
And so one example
of a heuristic
is just go to the
highest production zone,
which is actually shown here.
So the production that
Ben referenced before when
talking about the map Gini
coefficient is shown by--
I don't know how well
you can see it here,
but it's the back shading
on this visualizer.
So you see that the area that
this yellow player is going to
is a high production zone.
And so at the start
of the game of Halite,
it tunnels to that
zone and then starts
to expand so it can get a
jump on its production rates.
And heuristic bots
are interesting to us
for two reasons.
One, they're really democratic.
They're really simple.
Anybody with moderate
programming skills
can write these bots.
It's just simple logic.
And then the second point is,
it requires humans to actually
think through the strategy,
and it's really in line
with our human plus machine
way of constructing games.
When you use something
like Monte Carlo trees
that are generally
applicable to all games,
you're not thinking through
the specifics of that game.
You're just applying
that hammer, that tool
in the toolbox, to the game.
And the same is true
for deep learning.
But with heuristics
bots, you really
are combining the
power of humans
and the power of machines.
BEN: This also, I think, ties
into the educational aspect
of it, that by
forcing you to think
through the game and
your logic and what
the effects of your logic
will be on how your bot plays
the game, we think this
is a really important step
in teaching lots of younger
programmers how to get better.
This ability to
really visually see
how your changes affect
your bot and the behavior
is an incredibly
valuable tool in learning
to do so even more effectively.
MICHAEL: Yeah.
And then this is a more
complicated heuristic schema
for Halite II.
So we aren't going to
go into too much detail.
This was from a top 100
player in the competition.
And broadly, what
he did is every turn
he computed a gradient,
which is shown here in 3D
with the hills and the valleys.
And what he did for
each of his ships
is he looked at the
gradient, and he
had the ship go in a direction
that a ball bearing would
go if it was just rolling
down these hills, right?
And the whole strategy
of this schema
is encoded in a few
setup parameters,
and these parameters
are just how much
in terms of downhill-ness
or uphill-ness.
Various game objects
will affect the gradient.
So for example, you want
to stay away a little bit
from your own ship, your
friendly ships in Halite
II, because if you collide
with your own ships,
they're eliminated, right?
And so they'll have a bit of an
uphill effect on the gradient.
BEN: Yeah.
We do have lots of players
that do utilize machine
learning and deep learning.
So what you see here
is a diagram of a CNN
that was used to play
Halite I to great effect.
This was from user jstaker7.
So certain kinds of
deep learning methods
don't work particularly well
with Halite, namely the AlphaGo
style and Monte Carlo methods,
because the space is so large.
But lots of them do.
In this case, this
was simply trained
on the moves of the
top couple of users
and got handily into the top
20 of the competition out
of thousands of players.
So that's pretty good, we think.
We've also had players
used reinforcement learning
and policy gradients on
parametrized non-deep models.
That's also been used
to pretty good effect--
top 100.
Yeah.
And we are excited
for what's going
to continue to happen,
especially with Halite III.
I don't say too much,
except that we think
that there's a lot of promise.
We've been exploring
it personally
for what can be done with Halite
III in the deep learning space.
MICHAEL: And then finally, one
of the nice things about Halite
is that, since we try and build
in this multi-dimensionality,
there is both the element of
local play at the piece level,
and also there is definitely
an important level of metagame,
of metaplay.
And so we saw this in
Halite I, actually.
At the end of the competition,
a very important emergent
behavior in the
metagame was something
called the Non-Aggression Pact.
And it was basically
just an implicit alliance
between every player in a game.
If you enter the
alliance, the logic
that you encode in
your bot is that you
won't attack any other player
until they've attacked you.
And so, say if five out of
the six players in a game
put this logic in their bot,
that last sixth player is
going to be attacked
by all five first.
And so because of
this, all the players
at the top of our leaderboard
in the last few days of the game
encoded this logic in their bot.
It really exploded then.
BEN: Yeah.
It was very unexpected by us.
It's just a huge
shift in the rankings
in the last couple of
days, especially including
our very top user, who
probably was significantly
influenced by his incredibly
effective handling
of this whole metagame.
MICHAEL: Yes.
BEN: Yeah.
So then finally, we're going
to talk about our competition
principles.
MICHAEL: Yeah.
These are the principles
we take to heart when
we're building the competition
around the Halite games, so
stuff like our
learning resources,
our website, our forums,
our tooling, et cetera.
And so the most important
of these principles
is that they need to be very
beginner-friendly but also
powerful.
So like Ben said
earlier, we're dealing
with people on the internet.
They have minute-long
attention spans.
They need to be
interested by Halite
after just reading the
game rules for a paragraph
and looking at our
tooling, right?
And so one way in
which we make it
very frictionless
to onboard people
is we support 20 plus languages.
Most of these are
contributed by the community.
But that means that, if you're
a beginner and you like Python,
you can jump into
the game, but also
if you're a Rust
enthusiast, you don't
have to deal with the
annoyance of Java.
But also, we take this to
heart with her other resources.
For Halite III, we're
working on a web
ID for users who are not
competent in the command
line and also some more
interactive tutorial
experiences.
And then the second
thing we take to heart
is the competition is really
real time to its core.
So we've already mentioned
the continuous leaderboard
that is central to how
Halite works, and we've
heard from users that
that is one of the best
things about the competition.
For example, that third
user you see there, shummie,
is a very enthusiastic All-State
actuary who submitted 600 bot
updates to the competition.
And our median level of bot
submission was very high.
I think it was something
around 20-something for Halite
I was the median level.
So yeah, the leaderboard
got a lot of use
because you can make just
a small change to your bot,
submit it, and within
a couple of minutes
you're seeing that new bot
playing games against everybody
else on the leaderboard.
It's very immediate feedback.
And then we also need to
build in collaborative spaces
for users online, because often
other bot developers can help
users better than
we can help them,
because they've actually had the
annoyances, the frustrations,
the joys of working
on Halite, and we're
coming into it with
a lot of existing
knowledge about the competition
because we built it.
And so one way in
which we do this is we
have a discourse forum with
some nice theming shown here.
This saw a lot of use,
100-reply-long threads
about everything from bot
strategies to bug reports
to new tools that the
community has developed.
Somebody developed,
a third party user,
a very popular visualizer for
Halite II that saw a lot of use
on the forums.
And the second thing
we do is we also
have a discourse chat
that lots of players used.
And then finally,
what we're dealing
with on the back end of
Halite, which we haven't really
touched on a lot in
this presentation,
but we're about to, is kind
of a hard engineering problem,
because for Halite II,
we had about 6,500 users,
and we need to rank all of
these users very quickly.
And so we run tens of millions
of games of the Halite
on our back end to rank all
these users over the lifetime
of the competition.
And so this is hard
for two reasons.
One, we're running untrusted
user code on our servers,
so security is a big problem.
And then also, this
needs to be scaled.
We're going from
running no games
at the start of the competition
to many millions of games
in a week at the end
of the competition,
so we need our infrastructure
to scale up seamlessly.
And so Jacques,
our lead engineer,
is here to talk about that.
JACQUES: Thank you.
Thank you.
So as-- Hi.
Sorry.
So, as Ben and Michael said,
it is a very, very difficult
problem to solve, and for a
very, very difficult problem,
we require good architecture.
So that's how we use Google.
So Google has in
this way actually
granted us the ability to
solve all of these problems
in a very simple way,
almost plug and play.
And so right now I'm
going to walk you
through all the problems, all
the challenges that we had,
and how we solved them,
and how Google actually
helped us solve them.
First of all, games
are ripe with cheating.
The greater the competition,
the greater the want
for users to cheat.
And we store quite
a large number
of personally
identifiable information
here, including user
e-mails, among other things.
And those two
factors mean we need
a lot of security to
ensure malicious activity
is at a minimum.
And of course, we also
run a large, large amount
of arbitrary code,
as was mentioned.
We have 6,000 users with a total
of over 50,000 bots submitted
in over 25 languages
and lots of frameworks,
and that's a lot of
untrusted of code.
And, as I said, a lot of
personally identifiable
information, and all of
that adds to the problem.
Secondly, variable
ranking algorithms
need to play a lot of games
before fair convergence,
and especially if
there's a lot of users,
this increases
exponentially, which
requires much more
compute in many more games
and with a time.
And the outcome of this is
either general frustration
for users or large costs to the
administrators, and many times
both.
Regionality is
also a big problem.
A competition encompassing
over 100 countries
worldwide creates
some complexity.
Explicitly, how do we provide
equally fast responses
to players all over the globe?
Though we don't require
sub-millisecond responses
like a lot of multiplayer
games require,
we still need to do things
with some expediency,
otherwise users will be upset.
Reliability is a
very common problem,
but it's a problem nonetheless.
How do you make sure the
disturbances are minimal?
Users generally shy away from
anything, especially games,
they can't access.
And it doesn't matter
how fun you make a game.
If you can't play it, no
one's going to play it.
So for that, we need to
minimize the downtime.
AI is another,
well, quote unquote,
problem that we want to solve.
We want to make this
game amenable to AI.
And for games to be
variably solvable,
we need to provide both data and
tools related to the problem.
And especially as the data
increases, which in our case
includes megabyte replays from
over 25 million games, which
you can see is a
lot, the problem
becomes increasingly
more difficult.
So how do we solve them?
We have two types of
solutions we have here,
ones that we technically got for
free by using Google, and ones
that we had to build in house.
So I'm going to separate
them in all of the solutions.
First off, in terms of
security, through GCP
we got good containerization,
so we didn't
have to worry about that.
We managed to close all
internet routes going outside
of all our machines that
were running untrusted code,
so people couldn't do bad things
like, say, bitcoin mining,
in our machines.
We placed a good
number of firewalls
to make sure people just
weren't doing bad things
and talking to
machines they weren't
supposed to be talking to.
We created a large amount
of database in GCS isolation
so that only some machines
could talk to them.
And, of course, we used the
great VPC service controls
that are used widely that
really allow us to just talk
to the machines that we
want to talk and not have
any indirectness towards that.
And, of course, in our
in-house solutions,
we had a vast number of system
level defenses including
cgroups, IP tables,
among other things,
that allows us to really
isolate everything.
We had bot anonymization,
so if you're playing,
you didn't really know
what the other bots were,
so you couldn't exploit
anything related to that.
And we created score penalties,
like everything else.
I mean, you can think of that
as, really, an AI problem.
As people do malicious
things, you penalize them,
and they stop doing
malicious things.
So it's a type of
reinforcement learning
that we gave our users.
So for score
convergence, in GCP,
we had auto-scaling
groups, which
were great because
suddenly, based
on the number of users,
just automatically
became bigger or smaller.
And of course, that
lowered the cost.
And what lowered the costs
even more significantly
are preemptibles.
Preemptibles have
made it insanely cheap
for us to run a lot of things
and get very quick convergence.
In house, we had effective
scoring algorithms.
We used the best of the best
to make sure it was fast,
and we tuned it to the
best of our abilities
to make sure it was really fast.
In terms of regionality, this
was all on Google, thankfully.
Reliable regionality
toggle switch
is one of their best features.
So we really just used that.
And plug and play caching
and CDNs for website and data
respectively significantly
simplify the problem.
Google has its
famous mini nines,
which you can see based on
even the room you have here,
the Five Nines Room,
which makes the service
portion of this a non-problem.
However, the use of preemptibles
adds a further complexity.
Machines now can and will
go down at any point,
making our code redundant,
more specifically, duplicating
executions and services,
saving results, doing backups,
using health checks,
automatic restarts or creates.
And leveraging
fault-tolerant algorithms
is not a new solution, but
it's the key to reliability.
The solution, of course,
translates beyond preemptibles,
and ensures that even in
a rather faulty execution,
Byzantine failures
will be resilient.
Ultimately, Google is
very, very well-geared
to solving AI problems.
As you may have heard
in other sessions,
that's what they're amazing at.
By utilizing very powerful GPUs
and storing everything in GCS,
we significantly improve the
process for all the users.
For everything else,
we wrote a number
of training tools in
Python to simplify
the process in both interacting
with GCP and Halite directly,
which ultimately gives us this
picture, which is specifically
what our end picture was.
We had CDN serving all
of the important data.
Inside of our VPC, which was
well-protected, as I mentioned,
we had three types
of machines, all
done by management
disk groups that
grew or decreased as required.
In this sense, we had the
website, which literally just
served the website.
We had the coordinators,
which were the key API
and managed to send games
for the workers to play.
The workers could only
talk to the coordinators.
Meanwhile, the coordinators
were the liaison,
the mediator in between
GCS and Cloud SQL,
where we really stored all
that we needed to store.
And through that, we got
our complete picture.
And now, for why Halite,
I bring it back to Elsie.
ELSIE KENYON: All right.
So why, again, do we
care about Halite?
Let's go back to what Ben
was saying about game's role
in playing, in learning, right?
We learn through play,
but competitions also
provide an opportunity
to learn from each other.
They're not just about winning.
They allow us to educate
each other through play,
any age, any experience level.
In Halite, we've heard
examples of how players
learn by example of other bots.
There were trends in
different strategies.
Players also
contributed tutorials
and bought postmortems to
share what they had learned,
and also expressed
their creativity
by finding new opportunities for
new ways to play with Halite--
for example, writing their
names with their bots.
Technology really
enables this connectivity
and a successful competition,
but we see conductivity
all over the place,
including in,
say, moocs, which have
forums and tutorials along
with guided lessons.
We think moocs are not adaptive
or computationally intensive,
so they're not really
taking advantage
of what technology has to
offer for learning today.
Our goal with Halite is really
to exploit that possibility.
So games and global
programming challenges
running in the
cloud are immersive,
they're open ended
with potential
for any number of creative
strategies, as we've heard,
and they're adaptive.
So they're suited to
beginners who may just
be looking to gain confidence
in their first programming
language, but also provide
the opportunity for more
experienced players to gain
mastery of a particular skill
set.
Really, this is about
engaging with skills and tools
on your own terms.
So if we revisit this question
of how humans and machines can
work together--
let's go back to Ben
and Michael saying
that Halite is really about
humans working with machines,
not competing
against the machine.
We've seen at this conference
the increasing number of ways
in which humans and machines
are being paired together
or have to pair together
to solve problems
in the real world.
And the real world, as we
know, is highly uncertain
and requires flexible
and adaptive solutions.
So our question
is, to what extent
can games and collaborative
programming challenges
like Halite actually
serve as a training ground
for training and building
intelligent machines?
So playing a game is
not just about winning,
it's also about thinking,
through which we learn.
And with these
games we see there's
no path one path to learning.
And at the same time, we may
have goals and specific skills
that we'd want to
acquire, but those skills
have many applications.
So at Two Sigma, we take
learning and education
very seriously.
We take problem
solving very seriously.
And what we ask you
to think about is,
what are the ways to really
be engaged in your learning?
We think Halite, the
global AI competition,
serves a unique
educational function
with a lot of opportunity.
We'd love to hear your feedback.
As Ben and Michael
mentioned, we're
launching Halite III this
fall and you can sign up.
But in advance of
the competition,
we'd also like to design
it to make sure that you
can achieve your goals.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]